Film Courage: You talked previously about
lack of confidence. How much would you
mentally beat yourself up over things?
Andrew Warren, Author: Well
honestly when writing that first book I don't
think I beat myself up about it too much because
I didn't really have a plan of what I was
going to do with it. I just wanted to do it
so in that sense I think it was easier because
I just it was more about getting it done
to you know it's writing a novel at that time to
me seemed like such a insurmountable challenge.
I mean it really seemed like climbing a mountain
or something crazy. I was like so even if i could
just do it I would have been happy. That was all
that I was really sort of thinking about at that
time.I'd say the confidence more comes from in
screenplays and tv writing, things where you
really need to put yourself out there. I worked
that that writing job that i talked about that
i got really came about because finally after
many years and many opportunities where i could
have put myself out there i just started yeah i
don't maybe it was just the right environment it
was a very creative kind of young company and
everyone was super friendly and chill maybe i
hadn't had the right environment yet but i just
started to say like hey you know the development
executive would uh i remember one time he was uh
like kind of pulling out his hair and i was like
oh what's wrong he's like i forgot you know we
have to shoot this sizzle tomorrow and i need a
script and i didn't i didn't write it and now i'm
screwed and i was like i'll write it for you and
he's like can you do that i was like well sure
you know and i was like i figured how bad could
it be you know like they needed something and
they didn't have it so i figured anything's
better than that you know so i uh i wrote it
up and he took it home and then he called me
actually from the road and said hey i faxed it i
sent your script to the boss and you know he loved
it and he said who wrote it and i said andrew did
and he was like really surprised you know so from
that point on i started writing all of their you
know their sizzle reels on all their pitches and
uh i they actually optioned several shows
from me you know they didn't get made but they
they you know that was sort of where i started
realizing that you know it doesn't there's no harm
in putting yourself out there you know i just you
know once i got a little positive feedback it was
easier you know but i should have been doing that
years ago you know i mean always if you have ideas
share them you know put them out there even even
if people say no it can't hurt you know you're
going to hear a lot of no's in this business you
might as well get used to it but you never know
so do you think it's having confidence
or the rejections don't sting as much
and so then you're like oh well oh well probably
a little of both i mean certainly i think as you
get older it just starts to get easier because
you just inevitably accumulate more rejections
you know i mean it's like dating you know like
when you're in high school it's the end of the
world if the girl you like won't go to dance
with you but when you're 40 like it's just
another you know okay on to the next one you know
um so i i don't know what i don't know what the
i don't know the answer is but i think
it's really important not to let rejection
discourage you i mean i just think that's what it
all comes down to you're going to face rejection
finding your own way to to face that and
overcome it and just keep going and keep
trying things i think is really what's going to
separate you know the winners from the losers
can we go back to when you first came to la
and talk about confidence when you maybe got
off the plane or i don't know if he drove out
here well i think when i when i came out to la
i was super confident because we had this movie
and like we thought it was going to be great and
we thought we were going to be you know like
the next i don't know like clerks or whatever
was the big indie thing at that time and it
didn't go that route but even even so like we
were already on to the sort of the next thing you
know so i i i don't i think really what it was was
i think you it's super important in anything
whether it's writing novels screenplays
relationships anything i i always call it or i
say you need to be careful you don't give in to
lottery thinking you know it's like that idea
that this one thing is it you know and if this
one thing doesn't work out you're screwed that's
it you know it's over or if it does work out that
it's going to make you suddenly you're rich and
on easy street in my experience uh that's just
not you know the way it were i mean sure maybe
it works like that for a very small percentage
of people like that's why i call lottery thinking
but those are the people you tend to hear about
but even if you look at really successful people
that you know write a screenplay that that you
know does really well and launches their career or
that sell their first novel even even me and i'm
not saying i'm super successful at all but like
even my first novel it's not really you know i'd
written four or five half novels and dozens
of short stories you don't see all the work
that's kind of hiding in the shadows you know
you just see that one thing and so you think
if i could just get this one thing i'll have it
made and so i think that one i kind of gave into
that with that one script you know that i thought
would get made you know there's no reason why i
couldn't have kept shopping that script around or
why wasn't i working on another script you know to
follow that up i mean that went on for you know
probably that whole option period was probably
about two years um you know i certainly could
have written other things but i just got very
tunnel vision focused you know on that one
thing happening and when it didn't happen
that just kind of like i said took the wind
out of my sails and i just kind of gave up
for a while after that and that was in my
opinion a big mistake you know on my part
but you didn't go quote unquote back home no
because at that point i was pretty established
here in terms of working i had you know i had
a job and i had a girlfriend and a life and
so i didn't go back home and i still i don't think
i consciously gave up like i still thought in my
head oh i'll work on this and i still had ideas
and stuff but i can in terms of the amount of
work i put into it the amount of effort i put into
it i can see i really kind of just let it slide
from that point i sort of stopped putting myself
out there you know and that was a mistake do you
think that the fact that you finished um the first
novel that that gave you confidence that certainly
gave me confidence i think i mean there was a
lot of things i mean i finished the first novel
um and then i s a friend of mine she was a uh
english major she was one of my very good friend's
wife she had been an english major she had done
some freelance editing and she knew i was working
on it and she said as a birthday gift i'll do
i'll edit it for free for you as an edit so i
had done one edit like where i just sent it off
to a service but i knew it still needed a little
more work so i was like okay great like it'll have
like two edits and that'll get it into shape and
she read it and she you know she also had a very
favorable reaction she was like this is really
good like you know i got to the end and i was just
like turning pages to see what happened and so you
know she's still a friend still not a completely
unbiased opinion but it was like a little bit more
unbiased than my girlfriend you know so each step
of the way i'm like okay people seem to like this
you know maybe maybe it's not bad you know um and
then really you know i ended up self-publishing it
through amazon and i did that because i already
had some projects optioned at that point the the
tv shows i had mentioned and i had kind of gone
through that process a few times you know where
you're really you're you're sort of dependent on
someone else you know in essence unfortunately and
i just didn't want to do it again you know i mean
i knew i would have to for other feature you know
screenplays and things like that so i said maybe
i'll just do this for me and i'll just put it out
and i was fine you know if no one buys it or if it
doesn't do well that's fine it's out there i wrote
it i put it out there that was really all i wanted
from it you know um and i put it out and it did
well like not amazing i certainly couldn't quit
working off of it at the time but it did well and
more importantly the reviews were really good
and they were even more important than being
really good like i said they were exactly what
i had hoped you know i mean i put it out there
saying i want this to be like a mental vacation
for someone i want people to feel like they've
gone to japan i want them to like kind of get
an experience outside their normal life and i
want them to feel like they saw like this really
awesome action movie and that's what the reviews
were like i mean the pretty much all of my reviews
for all of my books the two things that come up
more than anything else are you know i really
feel like i was there and it feels very cinematic
and i'm sure that comes from the fact that i
had much more experience at that point with
screenplays than i did with novels and i guess
that translated but so when i started getting
those reviews i'd say that probably was the
biggest confidence builder because these are
people who not only don't know me they spent money
and bought it and they liked it so i i think once
i saw that i was like okay like i have something
here and i need to start you know pursuing this
did you promote the book at all once you had it on
amazon i did um you know there's a whole sort of
once i decided i was going to self-publish it
i did do quite a bit of research into how that
works and there's a lot of information out there
there are a lot of other self-published authors
and so i didn't just go into it blind and i
actually do consulting with other authors to sort
of help them because you really do need a plan you
know i mean there are i think when i launched it
there were probably like 5 million books in the
amazon store now i think there's 10 million you
know so if you just you know squirt it out there
and don't do anything it's you're probably not
you know gonna get it you know if you're if
your goal is just to publish a book and say
it's out there that's fine i mean i think that's
a worthy goal for many people but if you want to
uh make money off of it you absolutely have to
have sort of a marketing plan so um what i did
was while that uh editor while that second editor
was working on it i wrote a novella that was uh
prequel and so i started giving away the novella
for free to uh build up a list of reader and email
list of readers and then when the other book was
ready then i could email all those readers and say
okay now the sequel is available you know that
was sort of how i started it so sorry so tokyo
black was the novel but then you were preparing
it and then you wrote the novella and gave it
away for free yeah how interesting okay so while
the because it went through those two rounds
of editing the the novel uh in the second round
the the very kind woman who did it for free for
me you know it took her a while like you know
because she was working a job at the same time
so while she was doing that i'd say that probably
took two or three months like for her to finish
um so while she did that i i wrote the the novella
which i had you know directly designed as a sort
of prequel that would lead into it so how many
words is a novella uh that one was about 20 000.
and then the novel was about 85 000. interesting
okay and so you gave that away for free and then
so you had your website because you have
a beautiful website by the way because you
have these cool maps that you have one map that
i looked at where it it has like the different
books and it shows which country it corresponds to
and you know beautiful friend of mine he's also an
author his name is aiden he made that map he lives
in australia and i've worked with him on a few
projects and he put that together i could never
do that oh okay but he made it for me but yeah um
yeah exactly so i would give it away through
my website i also you know when you're an
independent publisher you're real or when you're
an independent author you are really a publisher
as well and so i had to learn quite a
bit about um advertising marketing um
and i started to dip my toe in all of that and
i ran facebook ads um you know i did uh swaps
with other authors in the genre where they would
they would give away my book to their readers and
i would give away their book and we would share
you know interested readers email addresses and
things like that there's there's a you know if you
once you start researching none of these things
are super uh like groundbreaking or hard to find
like if you're once you decide you want to go down
that path there's a lot of resources out there
there's groups on facebook there's books about
how to do it and you know these are all sort of
the standard tactics you'll hear people talk about
how did you know who your audience was when you
first started i don't think i did i mean i mean
other than that i mean look i think uh you know
definitely they there's a big thing in in writing
books about finding your ideal reader and i think
that's true to some degree but i also think people
go a little overboard with it because i mean i'm
not if i'm writing spy fiction that's a pretty
well tread genre you know i mean if you like spy
fiction you know you like spy fiction you know or
if you like science fiction you know you like
science fiction so i never really worried too
much about trying to pinpoint uh you know is my
ideal reader a 40 year old you know middle manager
with you know two dogs and whatever some people do
and if that works for them great but i just i just
thought of it i just tried to write a book i would
like honestly that was really what it came down to
you